hi guys I hope you have already seen
this icon in my youtube channel and
wondering what is this icon so before
telling about what I'm doing with an
Academy let me tell you about a problem
in India the Indian education problem
Indian education is now like a factory
people go in go out like machines and
the course starts with school and
colleges where the classes are generally
boring disgusting and you generally
sleep in class or end up doing Facebook
you wish your lectures could have been
more engaging or interesting
unfortunately they are not you spend
money after money in private tuition
classes still it does not give you a
quality education sometime you feel
depressed because simply you cannot
afford that amount of money and most of
the cases you consider yourself to be a
loser and you underestimate yourself
your confidence is broken
you always need someone who can show you
light show you path instead of shouting
on you they can listen to you they can
hold your hands and take you throughout
your course so I'm collaborating with
Khan Academy as you know an academy is
the biggest learning platform in India
whose motivation is eLearning and smart
learning so you can literally learn from
anywhere just if you have a laptop or a
phone that's it you can learn wherever
you want whenever you want and with an
academy the prices you pay is lowered
several times not only that there are so
many online free contents that you can
access I'm launching a course named I
teach am biotechnology crash course at
least for two months and literally it
would be extended for years so let me
give an overview what this course is
about for the free structures and
everything
so first of all this is the course
outline you see there are two platforms
one is an Academy's YouTube live channel
under the category of iit jam which is
completely free pause this video and
subscribe that channel if you want my
videos to be there and want to have
access to a free video I would be
definitely posting my videos under this
channel as well
which would be more generalistic
overview and also problem solving as
well now there is another platform which
is subscription-based that means you
have to pay some amount of some amount
of money but even if you don't pay any
amount of money you can always access
the free classes in this plus platform
or you can see me live then you have the
paid classes now you might be thinking
you have to pay a lot of money actually
not see the free structures they're
quite reasonable and these paid classes
can be obtained for years or can be
obtained for only one month pretty
flexible right using a code a p10 you
can get 10% discount on the price is
listed here so don't don't bother to use
this coupon code right now let's talk
about the syllabus in a little bit
details as we know our champ biology
syllabus is kind of divided into five
sub categories general biology
biochemistry and physiology cell biology
and immunology Moll bio and
biotechnology and then microbiology so
in this course I'll be covering all of
these so here is our course diagram and
it would help you to plan properly and
achieve milestones in particular time
course would start at December first and
you have to achieve such certain
milestones not only you we together
would achieve those milestones so we'll
cover cell biology and molecular biology
till the end of December and in the
second goal we would cover other topics
now this target of this course is to
feel more confident as you approach the
exam you need to have a deeper
understanding of the subject you should
plan your time better and definitely
this course would help you to increase
your analytical skills and you can pause
a positive video right now to see the
timings of the course definitely you can
access the course anytime but in order
for an open discussion or a to wait
interaction you need to log in in these
particular times now let's talk about a
short goal our first milestone and here
is the course outline for that so you
can pause this video and take a moment
to understand the course outline and
this is the course to outline which you
can also pause and take a look at the
contents and the digital planning of the
course is given in this table now as we
go further in this journey we'll share
more of these timelines how we would do
it how to plan about it all these things
I hope I can give you an experience
which would help you to problem-solve in
a creative fashion and help you to
manage your time and honestly my course
don't guarantee you a seat naughty or
any other promises so my course has no
guarantee no warranty but only one
guarantee is there it can give you a
better learning experience so see you
soon and hope you join this course let's
learn together thank you for listening
bye